got my weightlifting class at 8:45 on
Thursday so I can't do anything with you
I don't have I don't have don't make
plans when they had 8 from 1845 to 9:45
I'm doing explosive lift at him
yeah bro so what yeah so what I'm doing
that's early for you it's way too early
for me but I will I will warm up first
with the straight bar so I warm up with
the straight bar at the Venice barbell
club this is at the Venice barbell cloud
a great name
it's a great name with my with my coach
with coach Josh McCoach coach Josh yeah
what do you do well Olympic alternate on
the Olympic alternate team coach Josh
now do you pay him in food stamps and
how's that work he's the only big
alternate bro I only pick alternate yeah
so does he make 0 now does he owe
America money he's like he's the
instructor head instructor at the Venice
barbell Club so he actually knows his
[ __ ] no no no doubt you know that's how
it works you know your [ __ ] like being a
gymnast yeah I know your Sheikh not it
tumble tumble tumble in doesn't do no no
you know what you bill
cuz they get diggit no good he'll charge
100 bucks an hour and they got you got
CrossFit the competitors have come to
him and stuff like that so he's busy
yeah he's got he's a busy man but I'm
busy from 8:45 to 9:45 cuz I'm working
I'm working with heavyweight all right
I thought you did you take some time off
have you been doing it what happen you
better be careful now what the [ __ ]
you're trying to say when's the last
time you did it they're on to on on
Friday I think I can't remember the
point is consistently enough boy sweet
you don't do it enough I do it twice bro
no you don't I do it twice a week and
yeah I do well you're right I'm sorry
time off I'm starting to do it twice a
week usually tell me about why my voice
is deep because my testosterone super
spike we haven't done it yet
yes yeah I have I did it I did it on
Friday now I'm doing it anyway I'm doing
it twice a week all right
Thursdays and Saturdays Oh Saturdays
yeah he's in a class it's just
one-on-one just one-on-one right that's
them it's so boring when it's one-on-one
I know but you know what there's so much
Angelique I don't know how to do it and
I'm a little afraid of the way you're
doing all
with matching snatch hang cleans squats
I do some incline my face I do some
incline bench bro and you pay someone to
show you the incline then let me tell
you something and let me you have zero
friends who could spot you an incline
bench well that I can I'm there I'm
there I'm there
don't how are you doing incline back hi
since I talked to your coach right now
since I talked to the coach right now
whatever the whole lot he's doing for
that shut up
I do opposite since I talked to Phil
Heath and I he goes you gotta do incline
Mel's build a shelf I was like Jude
Allah got away I told you that nine
years ago oh I think they'll set that on
the podcast probably I will say this
about I will all [ __ ] aside I'll say
this about Olympic weightlifting or
doing like you know deadlift and stuff I
feel very good afterwards like I there's
nothing that makes me feel stronger and
more I'll just everything every way I
feel loose in the classroom yeah go
heavy yeah that must be what it is right
yeah um
snatch and stuff it you're a little
scary right three with it it doesn't
make sense I go super light with that I
don't care really my snaps and for what
just cuz in case I got a concave a like
in case they got a snatch something get
that up there Brian you know I'm good if
there's an earthquake get that one yeah
I got you know it means only take some
guys I don't know five six years to get
the technique right before they blow out
their [ __ ] but at 50 you got this
yeah I'm athletic
how about Rashad Rashad Toni Ferguson's
coach I'm asking questions about boxing
my back foot and stuff and funny goes a
man Brian listen at the end of the day
you always [ __ ]
boxer Burton right in my face he goes
man you owe this [ __ ] so it doesn't
really matter
well I don't know you that well because
evil is nobody's like everyone's like
hey what don't say that no man you also
because he kind of stopped themselves
and show me how you show him a move and
how balance and stuff like that he goes
man he just cuz his hands just came out
of a sock Brian you all this [ __ ]
I'll be honest with you all of this [ __ ]
so you don't really need to know about
this think about were they shot my face
can you call me out my [ __ ] you it's the
best beard ever I love that guy the
selearis
he's done well with Tony Ferguson I
asked what he what he does with Tony he
goes balance I work on balance
fundamentals yeah yeah so if I'm gonna
fight Tony or at least move around with
them you need to have that guy you need
to call that guy up Tony hey Tony Bryan
Callen I don't know if firing the kid
podcast do you want to move around a
little bit
hey this is who want to move around a
little bit and just go light you want to
go light you just move around yeah go
like no no ankle locks or anything else
maybe I need to do some oh I do deadlift
every week I don't know my energy has
been zapped all right guys ah yeah that
might dress although I feel uh quite
stressed I mean I'm worried there's a
difference between here's Mike's work
which it's productive like so I row in
yesterday we were both busy so we didn't
do find the kid but I'd Rogen and
meetings yesterday then so I find kid
today a big brown today we're fine kid
tomorrow
I've stand up tonight and then leave
Thursday for the tour 6:00 a.m. 6:00
a.m. that's good that's good no it's all
good it's not I'm not actually sleeping
as well as you think you are that's
that's what I'm realizing I always sleep
well though but I always have it's on a
sleep thing for me I was like I put my
head down at 9:30 I wake up at 5:00 with
my son because I'm a light savings [ __ ]
you daylight say hey farmer's [ __ ] you
anyway so stood on 17 doesn't make sense
yeah anyways um it's not sleep I'm I
think it's me it's my diet because since
it's because winner I'm Big Bear I'm Big
Bear Balkan I'm Balkan oh oh so things
slow down the cold mmm no things your
rhythm your circadian rhythm no me
Balkan all my bros are bulky right now
you wanna give you around the
bodybuilding.com forms we Balkans this
bulk season I didn't know I'm Balkan so
what'd you eat name something oh [ __ ]
it's one of those mashed taters mashed
potaters
yeah Taylor's got some taters and got
taters yeah you love you get yourself
some big old thick pieces of red meat I
don't weigh it down a little bit ah
last night buns and put extra cheese on
okay god that's gonna wash the dairy and
that we not wash to delve can party dad
that's that's a lot of sugar and we know
there's no sugar in compiled that's why
I drink it however but I made my Campari
so strong I get super bitter when you
know when you drink something you're in
charge gets higher sure it's not that
bitter so I barely put any soda water in
there yeah I was watching stranger
things too are you watching that
I'm not shout out to 11 I was watching
strange things too and halfway through
I'm like I'm faded yeah yeah I'm faded
so I'm tipsy right now because I drank
basically a giant glass of straight-up
Campari yeah that that'll that's got to
do something to your metabolism I don't
know that so I'll tell you it was
causing me I couldn't fair what the [ __ ]
I was why I was not why I was tired like
way behind they'll be well we're gonna
forget to the bottom is my problem is
Mike Mike [ __ ] my [ __ ] non-stop
jumping bean Corgi my non-stop jumping
bean Corgi can I be honest about your
core yeah I hate no oh I love them hey
but I so cute that they look at me yeah
I hate them no but I love him what know
what it's like I get to your house and
then the German Shepherd runs out yeah
and the corgis behind them he nips at
your heels yeah I want to just take him
like this a little short yeah stubby
legs yeah gonna take my - nope nope nope
right in his nose oh no and you and you
kill him he just dies because you know
what because you know what
he'll heard the whole family next to you
now the whole family's [ __ ] in a
circle like what the [ __ ] going on he
does live circle and nipping at our
heels does it relate he's not doing the
whole family together I'm like why can I
smell your breath right now well that's
a [ __ ] Corgi again when we're there
he just doesn't relax no there's no
chill so at night I just hear this ready
he's on the he's on the floor
[Music]
well [ __ ] watch this then see an
octopus just chewing I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he do like a giant rat yo giant
rat yeah
constantly something hey he's gnawing at
his paws he's [ __ ] he's walking around
with his [ __ ] long needle hello
what's going on here what I can read
behind between the lines huh I'll do it
for you
and I can rebut between the Lancer whoa
let me kill the dog I have no idea I'm
sorry my kids crying I'm a pause we're
not gonna stop this until we find what
boom new puppy hillier there it is let's
say you do it
whoa nail German Shepherd puppy admit
it's a stuffed dog no I loved that dog
no no hey thank you no no I love them
not I do too hey I'm not asking I don't
know why don't listen so I'm you're not
being subtle at all you're winking at no
I'm not
yeah you're waking up with both eyes oh
my god oh I'm just saying maybe let's
figure out why is your energy why is
your energy I don't know I never knew
moonlighting for guys at night I know
it's quite light is a question are you
going out to the lane I guess well
Gingka dude dude
Oh your nipples are pierced huh why
spread in there with no shirt on and a
hat no no feel like that gay life would
be easier for me though yeah um so
you're just Zach like a GU girl like
when you say as that you just don't have
the energy to get up and move around
like it's all an effort like I was
hidden mitts with Glenn yesterday and I
was and I'm never like this I'd be like
how much more [ __ ] time do I have
here like I don't want it are you upping
your sugar as your insulin levels spike
are you eating a lot of carbs in the
morning no I still fast in the morning
although I had avocados this morning but
both sides out usually fast okay I did
have three doughnuts on Sunday hmm what
about coffee does coffee give you a hot
like a spike in coffee as you feel
coffee is life okay but do you feel like
do you lose your energy later lesson
you'll drink coffee you get that that
adrenaline rush and then no I drink so
much of it there's no adrenaline rush
okay it's just life so your constants
like oxygen for me yeah it's like oxygen
I need my coffee okay not that cuz I've
been doing too long yeah so you you
basically were boxing with Glenn and you
lost your energy no I don't lose energy
ups for my cardio is ridiculous right
now I just didn't want to do a
ridiculous yeah ridiculous weird for me
man
nothing for me to hit me like I enjoy
hidden myths yeah I was like looking at
the clock I was like coming out and I go
and I never asked this I usually never
look at time I don't do any of that
stuff no I don't that my phone's not
around no that stuff
I'm focusing my workout and I was
literally like how many around you want
to do he's like we got six more like
yeah
I like my tech one Oh Chi Chuan I said I
don't have a lot of energy said there's
a mind I go I know but this is there
some other reason he goes here's how the
hardcore Korean goes if he was going to
make a lot of time is you tired
I go no it's mine same same so you're
not right when you're about the [ __ ] it
suddenly retire when you got to do work
so hardcore
Lin said the same things like it's all
mine sound like [ __ ] no I get that
and this isn't Tony Robbins here you're
talking about a guy who I lift or
workout yeah I'm like I don't need any
helping motivation I'm just I don't know
what it is
you ready to switch it up well I think
about this all the time I think I'm
eating too much protein sometimes
because then I get tired like maybe I'm
eating too much meat I don't fight don't
I really into me
you've the more energy than you and I no
no I get it like I know record you for
you don't have to I do this to my wife
my wife will hurt her tailbone she cuz I
fell on my tailbone oh my god my
tailbone hurts - she's like [ __ ] yeah
like I can't let her have any of her own
B's relating to her yeah yeah I don't
know man I'll get I'll get out of the
funk my shows were great like my show
and clouseau is great yeah I heard you
did my friends were there oh oh that's
how can they I didn't see man I don't
know they probably got intimidated or
maybe they did take a picture but they
didn't say damn it they should've man
hook them up you guys were they thought
you were really funny dad I brought that
they're like Brendan's really funny I
was like yeah yeah he's my friend
oh yeah good nightmare by now yeah yeah
I'd be Charlie Sheen tiger blood if I
was a that's right funny yeah Dan if
Emily laughs perfect Anna doesn't lie no
matter how famous you are you don't get
away with five minutes it gets quiet not
to get worth like Pete some people like
oh do you sell tickets cuz your friend
shop not that famous man I'm not [ __ ]
Jamie Foxx on the road you know it's not
like that no no clue says interesting
cuz it's a it's a casino on an Indian
Reservation you know the gentleman who
picked us up last time that you're sure
how to be Indian
he was an Indian and you tell me what
it's like to be in my shoes that was
just classic yeah explain him he is a
Chatty Cathy sure is yeah yeah sure is
like if like yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah anyways talking my ear off great
guy sweet but I brought that hey soos
tree hole with me yep Trejo he's a he's
a regular at the the commie story just
got past a little bit ago hmm please
because usually I don't you know if I'm
out of town you know how it is be bring
Stevie blue eyes or you know you voice
heads don't open up for you I don't have
anyone open up for me I hit the crowds
cold yeah people who are just being
thrown out there yeah that's a really
good way to learn yeah but then there
comes a point where you got a you know
you got a grandson with you so I decided
to bring hey soothe with me to this
venue but and then after other clubs I'm
just gonna have whoever they have local
doing it so for your local copy lightly
like legit local comic Charlotte
Columbus or natural let me know hit me
up DM me they might already but son but
either way I can I can talk to my call
who was over at Charlotte and get a good
opener for you yeah he's my boy he might
be doing it I'll talk to him but uh yeah
it's fun but the casinos interesting
because it's like we've done it before
but so what
I don't pay as much attention with you
and me cuz more doing shows that I Jeff
you and I just make each other laugh
it's hilarious but we need to stand up
by yourself like I the dynamic of the
room you can't I'm trying to think chin
to relate to something it's like a
ballroom so you can't hear the crowd
really cuz like about acoustic I can
only see the front row acoustics are so
important in stand-up and with the room
like that Clouseau and I were I know
where you were a room like that is is
not built for acoustics they don't it's
just a big room and when you have just a
big room that the noise dissipates the
noise isn't even and you feed off it
like certain bits it takes you know your
hearing your rhythm later that like the
sound system isn't designed for so and
you can't feel the energy because the
energy gets absorbed into their clothes
they're so big noise sound waves go up
to the ceiling so you're not really able
to gauge how you're really doing yes
feels like you're doing jokes in a
vacuum especially when you can't see the
audience so you can't measure their you
can't read their faces you can't see
because what you do and what I do what
people don't what what part of what
stand-up is is to be able to read the
audience that that side looks a little
tired let me go over to them this side
looks a little too amped up these guys
are macho and getting all crazy so I
have to put I got to ignore them for a
second to calm them down or they're real
or there's there's a bit where you might
have some more leg room there if they're
if it's killing it yes run with it more
yes but when I can't hear anything is
right yeah I'm just like I'm I'll it was
like I was doing in here with the light
that you can anchor you can anchor into
like somebody who's laughing a fuckload
it was great the crowd was great I
stayed after met with everyone it was
great inclusive you know they're the
best but that is just a different
dynamics not depressing at all after the
show and you're in real room casinos
don't yeah I just want to kill myself
the road is lonely when you're alone it
really is yeah we might want to just
pair up and start doing big theaters
Paris that's not a bad idea
ijuin and I go on first for like 45 and
why you do an hour why not cuz we
wouldn't have a great time are you open
for me um shoot what should we do with
the Corgi I'm just kidding we take the
Corgi with us he's our mascot
i stuff him so we don't have to feed him
we go to a taxidermist or there's equal
hate for your core game and just let the
fence let's slice people possible to
hate that little guy no he is cute not
yet
hey I'll take care of stop just offering
to murder my Corgi I don't need no I get
on your back I'm not your long a large
killer but I've known you long enough
where it takes what there it is it takes
one look I didn't even look at you man
you're reading into my face there blink
if you want me to kill your core you
know I don't want you to kill my court
just blink it is I didn't give you it
any kind of a look um I just do it just
you walk in I'm just like get this like
it's a human I'm killing killing the dog
well my dog stepped on my foot and my
daughter was there my wife was there my
dog my German Shepherd Stephanie I like
that and I was in a bad mood and I all I
do is I kicked I like my leg came out
and I touched the dog
the rebels get out of here like that
well my dog went oh my god like I
destroyed really kicked it my daughter
was like yo cat cat my wife was like are
you kidding me I'm with you kid they
attack me and I was a should I didn't
kick the dog I did not kick the dog like
real quick my dogs on actor I know I
touched you does not matter my dogs so
traumatic I was like I [ __ ] knew I I
nudged steer her in the ribs cuz she
stepped on my foot I'll tell you what
doesn't behind a family go daughters
dude your daughter boy not to that she
messing with dogs is one thing Americans
do not [ __ ] with asked Michael Vick but
yeah you can't kick it arm how about the
biggest game where I play initially
colorado's when he played Nebraska there
are [ __ ] nemesis whenever you played
Nebraska it was high there'd be the
schedule then in red is saying Nebraska
we just played in the last game of the
season and put forth the season they had
alumni coming and hype us up and talk to
us and I forget who it is but he came in
there was like three like famous alumni
before him that riled everyone up and
was like yeah [ __ ] the Cornhuskers then
once Isis but I comes up I forget he
played in the NFL I forget who it was I
don't know out him anyways and he's you
know what man I hate the Huskers so
[ __ ] bad
I don't wear red I don't have a red car
he's like I named my dog Husker and
everyone's like yeah wait what and I was
like where is he going with heels I
named my dog Husker so once a year when
you guys are playing them or you play
them I wake up I kick the [ __ ] out of
that dog hey go ahead every football
player and coach man I mean you want
about bombing but it goes damn it was
like and he goes do you get the point
maybe I'm not kicking my my dog like
he's trying to backtrack the huge bunny
was like Coach Barnett stuff singers
alright ladies and gentlemen oh let's
you know just move on my fire hands of
grace you told us the story about Alf
Gracie when he was younger alpha with a
maniac alpha used to own pitbulls and
his dog bit him in the face
he bite me and he [ __ ] choke the dog
he just grabbed the dog but he liked his
dog but he was bring up the dog of
breath seal Hierro
I think it's called
Brazilians yes how do you what is that
it's a giant mastiff dog Oh Artesia if
no it's similar right Brasileiro there
it is there it is
grassy Tierra yeah these are these are
massive massive guard dogs
yeah like cane Corsos yeah take a look
at that babies dogs are giant there you
go now it's a massive pitbull it's it
looks like a pitbull that cycle yeah and
alfalfa
Alf's this is Ralph Alf Gracie so
they're they're fight that's right yeah
I don't want to see that so they're
they're fierce animals huge yeah so this
is the story that stalls it funny
apparently off his gay his friend had
two of these dogs and they're very very
protective little cute
yeah but powerful and massive it's a dog
and and he his gay was sitting on like a
table in the backyard and how it was
like I want to try it I want to try with
gear today and they got and hands it was
like well you can't because the [ __ ]
dogs are literally screaming [ __ ] you
through the fence and they're lions so
you're not gonna get it he goes I'm
getting my [ __ ] gay and he's like I
know alpha I know but would even do
climb the fence and get your G they'll
tear you to shreds he goes I'm not
letting dogs dictate and so all of a
sudden he decides it's a challenge and
now he's [ __ ] really pissed and he's
dogs going and he's like hey he said I'm
[ __ ] I'm not letting dogs but and he
a grows out and apparently he climbs the
fence
John sound the dogs like oh like that
[ __ ] you [ __ ] stay that I'm getting
my key
that's all doing I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here and scolding them again
don't you hate a minute good either day
krasiki has like Gacha gate climbs back
over the fence and [ __ ] no problems no
problems in the gym to have other geese
for him to use no well you know it's
probably a point of you know yes Ryan
employee I would never do that to giant
dogs okay yeah nobody knows when a dog
bites you like that you you you've been
bitten and asked by a pretty hardcore
dog really yeah bit bit mean that's what
kind
chocolate lab you only a hole up you
know like well her I quell them with a
suburban chocolate labs now trike know
they're being a trouble that ripped a
girl's favorite face I was like eight a
girl chocolate lab ripped a woman's face
off she was she was a on pills and she
woke up in the middle night and the dog
was sleeping and she fell on the dog and
the dog flipped out and bit her face off
like pulled her face off that's it no
Judith she had a head transplant
they're super cute this one bit me my
friends tree was struck by lightning
they told me go look at and shut the
door me he was gonna attack my you don't
so friendly it's really hard to thing to
get them to actually bite no this one
thought I was breaking in this house
yeah that one looks crazy yeah now it's
it's the raw Wyler's it's the it's the
hi dr germ working german shepherd you
know what michael them I think vodka
Noah bites people they say cocker
spaniels Rachel Wawa's number one yeah
Park has their own more and they're also
tiny your tiny it doesn't really hurt I
was terrified of childhood growing up my
friend Leon had a chihuahua super scary
yet you know I [ __ ] hey look at me
though that Corgi consider it no I can't
do that
done I can't do it yeah my started oh
how about you know the the mall right
cross CA that that Westfield I forget
what it is now they've redone it wins
last time you went there total mall no I
get so mobbed yeah it could be a problem
for a person look at your jawline my god
dude I first of all the Grove in this
new mall by CA they redid they redid it
I take you know Joe and Tiger and I just
stroll around there but there's a I
don't know if you know Javier's there's
one Orange County now the Mexican
literally the best makes food is good
eat really good they're not given away
though no dinner Francis dinner I mean
Lutz for two - Hondo what - Hondo
so what that's food you have though but
it better be you know it's great
yeah not playing around - anyways
dollars ridiculous for lunch
anyways over there there's like the
flagship
Apple store but I like those outdoor
malls man yeah I do too
it's fun strong I've been there I know
the one in Century City yeah but they've
redone all I haven't been there a lot
leader yeah I forgot that evenings need
to I've been there forever then Todd was
like dude you gotta get this hemp latte
and I usually make fun of people drink
em lattes yeah means I'm Tony
game-changer so I'm like [ __ ] it went up
there is ridiculous this is a random
story but the last time I was there I
probably had just done old school with
the girl from Grey's Anatomy and I ran
into her and talked to her for a long
time about you know making them make it
in the business it was before she got
Grey's Anatomy but yeah and then I saw
Tony Curtis there in running shorts and
who's Tony Curtis bring up Tony Curtis I
saw him and famous famous movie star
like Burt Lancaster back in the day
let's see what's he been in everything
he's a he's one of the most famous
old-time actors and there's his wig he
came out in a he had a running shorts on
that were way too short with a giant
belly very skinny legs and a [ __ ] fat
dick in the throat a wig nope and a
giant wig and I thought you're wearing a
wig that's him Jamie Lee Curtis is I
wouldn't miss Jamie Lee Curtis is dead
oh well I would never recognize him ever
yeah he was very famous back on it I bet
when you're like thirty it's where I
have [ __ ] he look so good he looks
like you know fake tastes there's no no
this uh you know that's maybe the sweet
smell of success was the [ __ ] boy either
way so you ran into him yeah [ __ ]
yeah I don't know him but I'll tell you
what age time really well they're close
with the body
father time man it's a Paul's iing [ __ ]
by the time can be a tough one man uh we
didn't shoot you're not even talked
about zero can I tell you anything but
uh uh uh you watch the fights obviously
I did watch the fights were you super
lonely kept sending out in texts like
hey you want to come over my house and
you like keep saying attacks out that
your friends text me okay your calendar
friends are gone well I'm not gonna god
no you're but you know you at the family
stuff huh right and so I got I got to
Stevie's gone dubs gone all my friends
are basically gone yeah me Rogen if a
rogue never hangs out Rogen heroes than
me but worse than a bye
never see him so I can't rely on Rogan I
can't really rely on you I can't rely
left me that's right he left me Frank
Frank Frank I see but he's working so
much he's always gone I'm in Israel I'm
in Atlanta he's doing x-men in Atlanta
right now he's very successful very
successful yes sir he's place crossbones
and then he's going on to another big
movie he's never stops working
so his shows on Netflix yeah Fabrizio's
in freaking Saint Barts I got nobody I
got nobody I'm alone and you know what
I've resorted to there I'm Emma said
escort nope I hang with my neighbors and
this is the beekeeper you want to come
over the beekeeper Jim Jim's one of the
guys I've invited but even Jim blew me
off even Jim Jim [ __ ] is my baby
Renee don't applaud me coming a great
guy here you wanna come over to us I got
plans tonight but thanks I got another I
got plans like I can't even get Jim to
come on every you know it's right next
door
yeah I'm not trying to be a dick yeah
but do you think you're the human
version of your Corgi I might be why
people I think people are I think yeah I
think I have a shelf life I think what
happens is people like either honest or
you that doesn't stop but also he's
awesome he's amazing and then they're
like um something about that guy's I
gots that do we have to go do we have to
watch that movie again you know I mean
like it's like but channel 13 reruns
like Brian again I didn't take my nap
tonight so I went to go over there
that's gonna be very tired routes the
fights by yourself now watch some of my
neighbors
oh they end up coming over yeah those
been a blast
it was don't ever text me actually some
pretty cool people coming over so if you
want to stop I know dude that was such a
good you coming or what no I'm at the
house but you know what anything I can
do that's it I think you know I don't
watch fights at people's houses yeah I
know act some pretty cool people coming
over
dot dot dot I don't respond like
whatever I got Campari for you yeah
gonna grab some steaks man just burger
medium-rare
what are you thinking nothing nothing
nothing
hey bro one wrote some ideas by you
won't come over for a few and
anything anything now I got nothing but
I was those fights were [ __ ] amazing
what's with you neighbor have we just
dropping knowledge is really kind of
called yeah of course thank you what do
you know me
I'll drop knowledge I talked about how I
spar over Dallas how I know the guys how
is bar with those guys I talk about what
it's like to write I mean I'm exhausting
but the beekeepers like oh but yeah but
I have to say that [ __ ] that for
those fights and you did secretly kind
of call all those fights a little bit
well you sound pretty honest you said
you were worried about remember what
Tony was on I was like don't worry about
me and ginger I'm not gonna sit up here
and be like oh I called rose beating you
wanna I did it she's a little first
thing I said what I saw her moving the
first thing I said was I went it's
because one of the guys there who loves
him I may watch this all the fights goes
Johanna looks a little off and I went I
don't see that I just see Rose moving
really well like I really was impressed
with her movement she looks so loose and
coming in and out fainting and stuff
like that it was amazing and then you
know just catching her with that that
that left you did you see the the way in
where you're honest interface shouting
she's reciting the Lord water I go uh
when I saw them like oh she actually
does have some mental health issues they
need to get a chopper to hurry but now
that I thought she was so afraid that
she was doing that no and she's not
she's like oh that's what I do cuz you
know I'm faith in my life is what I need
when it hurts and my life my life goes
bad I'm like oh do your thing girl yeah
but if if let's say she went there got
murked that Lord's Prayer looks super
weird yes but now that works you know
it's all good I I thought Jana was very
Rhonda ish where she was trying to hype
herself up and talk herself into beating
her and do all this stuff and you know
let's not heavy lies the crown I'm gonna
be champ man I I will be honest I got
emotional at that my heart broke for
Jana my super well for y'all and heart
soared for for Rose for sure and and I
mean Rose and I I think if they fight
again I don't know but I can't wait for
the fight and I wouldn't be surprised if
Rose does it again
sometimes a fighter can double you're
asking me tough it's gonna be tough
right why do you mad
because I think I'm not taking anything
away from Rosa and maybe it is a matchup
thing but I think Jana overlooked her
she didn't know animal she was dealing
with I think if they fight again I don't
think Rose finished her in the first
round I think Rose can definitely beat
her again right but I think they fight
ten times or given a different result
every time every time that that remap
that's a legit
let's give me a legit legit trilogy
watch it that's what we want that's what
you need
yeah I would love that yes and I think
you all should get immediate rematch
being a hard time defending champion
what she did in the division she's a
name now those other she's beat all the
other girls I think that she's excited
and it wasn't really competitive you get
knocked down the first round in three
minutes
yeah 303 yeah man I it was just so
impressive and roses athleticism is just
she's like water just bow so soon as
Rose is refreshing where she's like you
know I just I'm take this trash talk low
this should be nice to each other and
she's beautiful and she's awesome Rogan
Rogan thinks she can be the biggest star
in the u.s. I 100% agree with really I
disagree right now really yeah well I
really don't have time to get into it
with rowing yesterday I was more
surprised well I think she has the look
and the skills I don't think you're a
girl at 115 pounds can be the face of
the UFC it's just that's what that's
where I got her it depends on her
competition it depends on a competition
there's a lot of competition there but
none of my stars but they're all killers
they're all tough matchups for those
thing is too is that nice guy role
doesn't make you a superstar here's what
I like here's why I do a hundred percent
now you go GSP it's differ you're
talking about a guy who moved a nation
who's that 170 pounds but here's here to
defend the bottom at 12 times the
x-factor Rose has gone for you her
though here's the x-factor
Rose is so unlike traditionally feminine
she's so effeminate she's as great an
athlete as she has as much of a killer
as she is very still embodies this this
gentle beautiful female form that makes
it even more mysterious and more amazing
so I I I'm just speaking so in that
sense being this gentle spirit as row
at 1:15 I think would work I don't think
it works for a lot of people if anybody
can get away with it it's rose nothing
cuz because she's got and I hope I'm
wrong I'm just saying I hear the nice
guy role doesn't really like look at DC
great guy speaks well my funny talented
undefeated besides John John fights
heavyweight title holder and Strikeforce
ridiculous didn't leave a lot of
openings for me when we sparred yeah I
bet it's super nice yep not a draw look
at the other Mighty Mouse yeah look at
all the guys Woodley super nice yep not
a draw yeah
wonderboy not a drop all these guys
super friendly super you know I'm saying
I'm not tip Kody Covington with his
tweet to John to y'all I sent you that
homers is that shut up you lose instead
of you know the biggest fuck-up in the
sport here are the talkin you know they
were roommates Oh College oh I did not
know that Kobe and John Jones were
roommates I'm pretty sure can you look
that up they were yeah a community
college so they knew each other they
know each other well I bet cold I gotta
get Kobe on there we got to get Kobe on
there yeah this would be ground baked up
I'd love to get him on home yeah he's
hilarious
he is right hilarious no apologies just
gonna I tell him I go hey people tell
you don't cross the line I said you find
that line and [ __ ] burst through it
is whatever you're doing is working
don't get racist but Wow yeah former
roommate like so Robert Whittaker nice
guy in the world right and he he like
politely calls out GSP goes it'd be an
honor to fight you you're a legend
hashtag we do it anywhere
yeah but and hey I'm all for people
being nice I'm just saying if you go
back in the history of mixed martial
arts nice guys finish last as far as
being superstars so I don't know if you
talked to Stan this with Rogan but I I
thought the fight with GSP was
interesting in that as I watched the
great one which he is never found number
one no I think so and just is amazing
it's finding where you are he'll you'll
just he's a master named Mark or told me
that he's an amazing chess player which
makes hazing amazing biggest chess
player yeah he's got such a strategic
mind that he can see well-read
sure here I'm where you're open he's
into like the history of war like the
art of war I manually said that book art
of war with them and he said a lot of
history books with him he likes the
history of fighting that make sense wars
he's a student of the game
but um I noticed for me that when he was
throwing with Michael Bisping it didn't
look like the old GSP and that he looked
like he was closing his eyes and turning
away right there it is
he's turning his head away right now
maybe that was a strategy it looked like
a liability so let me start with I you
know I think George he he looked great
after four years layoff he looked
amazing as far as doing why he did it
after four year layoff that being said I
thought that was the worst version of
George we've seen foot work was slow I
thought he was flat-footed stamina was
awful he had the only reason came back
his Bisbing was the perfect opponent
well he had trained with Bisbing right
and destroyed him yeah yeah so I thought
the only reason he decide takes fight
because Bisbing was a perfect opponent
so when the people go he didn't have the
same nerves he looked good cuz again
I've trained with drawers I've been with
George in the back for his fights well
the same fight cards but you know George
doesn't deal with well with nerves he
gets more nervous than anyone any was I
think he's over the hump no he's over
the hump because you knew what animal
he's dealing with it's the unknown which
gives you the nerves when you fight a
guy in Bisbing which was the perfect
opponent that's why it was in nervous so
you know as great as George is and after
four year laughs and to finish Bisbing
like that is great and my hat's off him
for me he's pound for pound number one
of all time now we sort through Jon's
issues he's number one that being said I
thought that was the worst version of
George we've seen and I don't think he
beat anyone else at 185 I think it goes
to 70 and he look great I thought I
thought you know Bisbing and Judah guy
granted everyone goes oh he went out on
a shield but he didn't fight like it was
his moment my dear friend I noticed I
think he looks like that to me yeah he
looked a little softer I don't know what
it was he just might be age might be
father time but her I also didn't think
Bisbee was not aggressive he his
footwork you so afraid of the takedown
he was at Bisbee
you know I'm saying yeah yeah
but I mean half again I love George I'm
taking anything away from I thought he
did great
hopefully the car does over a million
best of all time now that that
pay-per-view is the best of all time in
the fights before that we're really good
to well so I didn't realize and I should
have but I that that TJ and Cody have
had that past relationship a big brother
little brother and big brother little
brother is a like I'm sure Cody was
doing whatever he could to get over that
but that there was his coach that's a
huge thing that's a I think that's a
very big thing because you kind of have
to like every time I feel like anybody
who fights TJ they're trying to like
manufacture a hatred like you left out
for mail you're a chair trader there's
all this stuff that never feels real it
always feels a little it feels a little
Coco DS Cody's was real I can get white
team alpha male feels that way but it
seemed like a bitter and like and this
isn't just on Cody I love Cody he knows
this this just wasn't on Cody it was the
whole team alpha male tribe it felt like
a bitter act but you left and you're
doing well that's why I'm feeling like
come on yeah here's it to a point for
you who made this point but there's a
difference between trash talking and
then defamation of character hmm him
saying he's one you know in and I get it
and all love is in all fair in love and
war but when you make steroid
accusations when you say you're the new
show team alpha male how to do steroids
the it's defamation of character yeah
that's dare I agree with you that's
different the saying I knocked you out
you don't have to show me where to do
that yeah yeah it's just that's when it
becomes personal I think that's what
Rose is talking about to like it doesn't
make me feel good when you start doing
that like tease each other
[ __ ] with each other a problem but
that's what the market demands and
people go shop you're such a high boy
and you're the one that types this stuff
up that's what the market demands so if
if Rose fights another girl where they
don't talk any [ __ ] and they talk how
great each other on our I like it now I
like [ __ ] talk but watch this I think
there's a crazy about creative [ __ ] talk
it's like this it's like dude you get
wobbled what happens is you break in the
third round anybody who takes you can
get into people's heads there are
creative ways but you know I'm saying so
this this was an actual animosity and
that's what makes this fight the
greatest bantamweight fight of all time
because there's that real animosity why
was that animosity because because in
it's so much to get into in his personal
[ __ ] there's per wolf it's because you
know TJ left team alpha male he's part
of it left them they think he's a
traitor he's a snake it was a vote but
but you could make the argument
historically it was the best move ever
Chang and became the rejected and now
it's world champion again and it never
looked better
because obviously that marriage between
he and bang is is a work of art I think
it worked out for both parties cuz now
Cody's the top dog and all the focus on
him TJ does his thing over here but
they're gonna fight multiple times right
there's no Reid I get I would imagine
there's no immediate rematch although
there could be immediate rematch because
the UFC's trying to put this rocket
launcher on Cody he's the face that knew
Kobe Bryant drink he's in the
commercials so they have all this
marketing vested in him so they could go
let's do it me at rematch just we've
already put some money into this he and
we need this to work out yeah
but to TJ's point he's the chairman how
much say he'll have in it kotiga should
be fighting and Mighty Mouse next yes
and Cody's gonna dot his vision stuff
although I was worried I was worried in
that fight to TJ because bang told him
to bang was like keep pressing and I was
worried because that's a bad thing to do
against Cody that could be a liability
and it was in the first round we got
caught [ __ ] yes cuz Cody is a really
good boxer and if I feel like is the
hardest another do anything and I feel
like if you are walking towards him and
making your move toward him that's what
you could give you a liability so you
have to really beat Cody yeah you know
why I'm like take it forward hell no no
so it's better to go toward him yeah you
want a mom either way momma's back
either way bang and TJ obviously know a
little more than I do about this and
that strategy I think and I looked at PJ
and Cody if they fight ten times it's a
different result ten times really which
is what I don't you think TJ beats me I
think I think TJ beats him eight out of
ten title no no no and I'll tell you why
I think TJ has a higher I think TJ is
just more skilled at the end of the day
and then you know this is what I think I
think I think I'd say what I think
Cody's a better boxer I think Cody might
be the best boxer along with Conor
McGregor in in the game he's of such a
good boxer and you
see it when he fought Dominick Cruz like
his footwork is I mean he did some [ __ ]
like an and Dominic will he's a
whirlwind and he kind of confused his
fighters not Cody Cody was like I've
seen this before you're doing stuff you
you've watched a lot of fight tape and
you've watched a lot of boxing fight
tape because if you hear Dominick Cruz
talk about that he studied all these
guys and a lot of those moves are old
boxing moves and he puts them all
together and he's kind of a genius hi
fight IQ but Cody understands that and
Cody's such a good boxer and I think
that's why I could he was able to shut
all that [ __ ] down because he could see
it coming before it did now I think that
that that if you are fighting a very
good wrestler and a very good boxer
which is what Cody is really good put
some both together really well and a
very good athlete hits really hard
however I think that with bang and TJ
together they because they fight on more
angles they fight even more on Orthodox
add to that TJ's insane competitiveness
his really good wrestling his sick
wrestling and his his the fact that he
can rise so well to the occasion it's
like he's the best he is when you put
all the pressure on him told he's pretty
[ __ ] absolutely absolutely but that's
why I think that at the end of the day I
think MMA wise I think TJ is a more has
more in his arsenal he has more maybe is
kicking I I think wrestling I would give
it almost equal especially based on what
Cody did as a freshman from Ohio but
winning the the state championship is a
freshman described as focusing on mixed
martial arts college you know in high
school as a freshman rush won it was
like I'm all good on wrestler I'm a
focus on MMA and boxing I don't think
those guys are so equal I think you know
TJ's kicking is what can mix it up but
I'm heating uses wrestling because
they're both aware of how hard they are
to take each other down never he's
actually now a punch to though at the
same time right so his punching is well
not to be underestimated in any way no
not at all not at all I but I think
those two are so close you haven't seen
them fighters in a trilogy and I it's a
toss-up every time it's a toss-up yeah
every time I would say
I would say that a lot of this is where
mentality comes in like what is your
emotional and mental state night of the
fight like that can be a play a huge
factor and I feel like I may be wrong
but I bet you Cody might be more of a
sensitive person to I'm telling you this
week there there might not be as far as
being a professional and being
competitive TJ's right up there if I
have to pick one person who one leg
injured mom just died whatever as far as
a straight-up serial killer focus
Cody's number one really he will fight
you in here you will fight you on the
set of UFC tonight you will he's not
professional when it comes to that he
will fight you is he if he sees you how
to fight in a kid live show he does not
care you talk about soaking he's so
competitive yeah it's in sick he's so
competitive it's a liability
that's how competitive that [ __ ] do
this yeah well good that's what which I
think on the rematch I think he's new on
a tear I think whoever fights him next I
feel sorry for he's going ter just get
back to TJ yeah then we're gonna see the
best of best hmm because I don't think
that was the best Cody I think he was
dealing with some injuries I know TJ was
had a back issue I think TJ was dealing
with some injuries so I but I don't
think that wasn't the best Cody I think
there's some other factors outside the
cage that were influencing his
performance and he's gonna rest and he's
gonna come back and I feel sorry for the
guy to fight him hmm
I'm excited this kid is excited about
MMA it is the night this [ __ ] gets me so
excited about MMA and I want to see who
does GSP is is it Conor McGregor's GSP
it's like honor no no too small like
he's just too small there's no way he
deals with his wrestling how does it do
it doesn't matter it's all so and I are
fans are rolling their eyes when we talk
about the matchup that's not definitely
not next I know for sure that's not next
so who is next for do you have any
inside scoop on who you think could be
next for GSP it's either it's either
locally or retire Woodley or retarder
boy why would he follow that's right
he'd fight the champion if I were you
yeah it's either Woodley or retire he's
not fighting Whitaker no matter what
Dana said that's not happen
no he's too big too fast if you remember
GSP in the cage when they were like a
let's go over this he's like I don't
remember any of it and then the venom
thought it was kind of alarming how long
he was up walking around the cage after
the you know he's taking pictures by
himself in there and then he didn't do
any interviews went straight to the
hospital do you think that was because
he got concussed for sure docking test
from those elbows and he got hit yeah
yeah yeah you just learn that knockout
artist but if that car Whitaker lands
that on you it's your the nights over
yeah yo Romero lands at nights over Luke
Rockhold night those are two big Woodley
nights over over it Willie's not an easy
walk to hide choose I choose GSP against
what lay in that I don't know I didn't
really um hey man um people think I'm
hang on you see I'm not at all he's my
favorite fighters of all time yeah a
good friend of mine yeah straight up
yeah I'll text the guy yeah I think
Woodley free it for him you know
although I just you can always speak
your truth I think Woodley's a rough
matchup for him why I think the game's
evolved a lot and I think especially if
Woodley shoulder it's obviously depend
on his shoulder but if Woodley's hunter
percent healthy it's just a bad matchup
for do you remember what do you remember
cuz I was at that fight do you remember
what our boy Rory MacDonald did to
Woodley yeah how he got right in his
face he ran up and stood right in his
grill and just jabbed him and just
jabbed the [ __ ] out of him and just that
shot him he but I'm on a different first
of all Rory and geosphere completely
different I think Roy's definitely
evolved more than GSP and you're dealing
with different Woodley my championship
mindset it's completely different than
when you're not hmm
I'm not crazy about that matchup for
just me do you think that GSP is
wrestling is better than Woodley's MMA
Wrestling yes yeah if they're if they're
in a wrestling room no although I've
seen GSP go against national Canadian
Olympians and do work yes woodleigh's a
[ __ ] mm-hmm uh-huh it's a it's a
good fight yeah I remember
Jimmy's a lot older and he doesn't cut
weight at 170 in four years by the time
they fight almost five years so cutting
what
that much weight and he was thick as
[ __ ] whoa and and remember now you got
you saw it and there's no IVs either
here he looked like a sheep Ponzi to me
man he looked like a blonde chimpanzee
he had he was just trapped out of his
mind wide pack super thick Tommy that
thick muscled Tommy Tommy Tom Howard ugh
is Tommy Tommy actually stuck out
farther than his chest bring him up I
want to see his tummy Tom does his tummy
tom was just he's just not not George
st. Pierre so maybe at 17 figures out
and you got some issues I'm just saying
if I right now gun to my head
I got Woodley in that matchup I'm gonna
tell you this I will never bet against
GSP I hear you never bet against him and
I shouldn't very happy with his body
there that was him at 70
okay look at that Tom talking down seven
he looks good there that's that 167 uh
bring him up
so right now yes he needed something
like this though [ __ ] yeah dude there he
is there's that Tommy there you see him
but he's not fat no he's not fat he's
strong as [ __ ] it was the best night of
his career really yeah I'm happy for a
man yeah he's awesome
he's [ __ ] awesome we really wish
Michael Bisping will retire me too
because I like waiting for like him so
much
yo Romero he's proved to eat the most
winningest fighter in UFC history
champion he's proved everything and I
love the guy I love everything about him
I don't want to see him get hurt don't
want to lose his eye and I want to fix
it Michael fix your eye you're awesome
you have nothing more to prove fix your
eye be a great TV commentator he's got a
great night TV come to whatever it is
he's great at like he's got a great
personality he's funny as [ __ ] he can
speak Michael Michael you've done it all
please don't lose your eyes there's also
I can I there's also no reason to hang
your head about losing a superfund out
he's awesome just what are you gonna do
you like these you'll reveal who Brock
will next don't want to get hurt I don't
want him to get hurt he's so competitive
though Bisbing has been fighting since
he was 14 you can go on YouTube and see
fights of him when he was 40 bucks it's
done
like you're awesome you proved it all
just be
be a personality now please hardly all
guy to do that you know I'm telling I
dad he's deaf get list if the one thing
I do know about Michael bhisma I love
the guy you're not telling him tell him
[ __ ] he's just too much of a fighter he
just loves it
he's just like him getting into it with
[ __ ] uh you know Mazda ah that was
interesting that fight wonderboy yeah
yeah the two for wonder boy he has to
have the right dance partner to knock
you out the guys at the upper echelon
aren't gonna take those risks so you get
kind of boring fights out of them but
it's not Wonderboys fault it just so
goddamn dangerous guys like hell no I'm
not engaging in that yeah uh your take
my take on Paulo Costa the Superman the
ridiculous timepiece tell us the
best-lookin their cz fighter of all time
I've never seen anything like he was
during the post-fight show I was Syrian
in my you know I was singing in my head
I went I bet he [ __ ] all the ring card
girl like if he doesn't it's he should
be impregnating everybody including my
wife I want one of his kids the guy is
such a handsome [ __ ] it's ridiculous I
mean he's stupid looking that's that's
it he's I mean now
now Paolo Costa that's a lot of myself
listen to me that gold snitch comes
sniffing around you now cuz without a
bit of a star yeah you do what you can
to avoid that yeah now they either have
the best genetics I've ever seen in my
life in fighting he still got amazing
genetics you don't get better genetics
than that he's even his face he handsome
the umj but not we just out of control
right oh yeah all right what do you mean
out of control does he make Brian look
like every Weinstein yes the answer is
yes and it hurts me I mean look at him
he's beast that's again that's a
fuckload of muscle to feed oxygen to
though so what did you think of him I
mean obviously he dominated Johnny
Hendrix he's dominated everyone he's
fought yeah you know he looked great
Johnny Hendrix has no business being in
there with him but I do I'd love to see
him against you know
another top 15 guys way to curse I'm not
again people think I'm hating I'm not
ready to jump on board saying he's the
next world champion middleweight I need
to see Johnny Hendrix should not be
fighting let's just be very clear Johnny
Hendrix should not be finding especially
at 85 yeah because of discipline reasons
he's at 85
so for Paolo you think the first team
all dimepiece I would listen if we're
having drinks in Brazil and you throw a
wig on me hey well I brought one and
there's some acai with cocaina na yeah
take it easy what would I be say he said
man I'm high and you I'm hard I'm hard
oh I'm on the toughen of a see let me
see if I can hold you down am I gonna
try here now given space am I gonna try
getting up flick him of space with me
get strike double space I already heard
you horrible man horrible man let me see
how hold you down oh you can throw you
down you Brown you big brown eyes brown
eye this real Brown wanna train with you
now
you know forget geez yeah look my mouth
look my mouth no you have you have a you
have mouths like there have a good
Russian man
what's a [ __ ] I'm losing my [ __ ]
you're losing it Brock man either way
first team all dimepiece and I would let
him try Lee Kevin Spacey experiment with
well he's such a beautiful man he very
very well is but um he's such a
beautiful man poor Johnny Johnny's just
tired of it probably right I'd be like
I'm wearing my t-shirt I got a fun hey
girls can wear the UFC fight kids and
their [ __ ] you guys do the exact same
thing though I have a rash they're all
Johnny you can't I want to turn my staff
you have tits
no we can't have it well Misha day
that's tips you loud her to do it about
my wife my wife cuz I gotta look at the
guy she goes man super muscular I don't
know it's not my thing I go this she was
who's the guy with the beard I like him
I was like a I've got the lures of
course you're the worst days what's
weird is I see Joe do I go is this Paul
guy just a straight dine P so am I going
crazy if she went he's not Rylan they
shrugged their shoulders like it
down tomatoes we know the man's dream
he's a man's dream we all like we're
like what the [ __ ] but I think he's so
gorgeous and so pretty
he's like Cristiano Ronaldo right yeah
like ooh and I'm like Cristiano Ronaldo
is amazing most girls like nah well
until he shows up until the no Julian's
out of that Bugatti in an all-white
started off and then all white tucked
and then he's tipping just grando's too
you know they all funny see that that
Madrid dick and correct yeah oh yeah
okay Oh monster with a tail let me
explain something to you that guy right
there if we're all hanging out and we're
at the pool and all the girls and all
the guys and we're just laughing so at
night when drinks start to flow he's the
first to [ __ ] and I don't care what
anybody so I don't know about that maybe
I mean I don't know what his gift of gab
is but your iced his English isn't great
but again that doesn't matter that
doesn't matter man no one do this chin
and he sent me a message on Instagram
shout to this guy ripped my pants dude
that's just my big that was my balls I
um anyways meek look up meek he's the I
forget where he looks like a vikin
Brogan our time I'm yummy us email me go
to his Instagram now that I'm surely
going stitches sniffed around both these
my if there's if there's this is a white
dude with better genetics than our boy
no no go to this back up back up there's
a pool shot scroll down hashtag I was
looking at scout this morning not gay
scroll down wait do you see this I'm
getting out staring keep going off
[ __ ] he's out of pool and I'm like
how the [ __ ] is he like this oh there's
a pool there this was come on bro yeah
so best body in em and a period those I
do burry those are some serious
shoulders and traps he's just flexing
their maybe you playing jazzy from
Iceland
we're C from Baja is the Nordic God
that's where heaven for the north for
the for the north is Nordic yeah but
yeah that's the Sweden that skin that
this Vikings went to Valhalla
Valhalla I am coming but then if you go
to his Instagram he shows a picture of
him I think I like 14 he's pretty jacked
and he
might just be one of those [ __ ] nez
de oh yes I think right or Ozma nordland
Desna and Eska Nordland where the [ __ ]
is Norway all right and then you know
what he also sings I think oh go back to
the inn sera he's white he's 170 pounder
511 um
maybe he's a [ __ ] that maybe he's
from Norway he's a true Viking nature
and go back to Sisko is there any sound
here's a band scroll us look at how
shredded here that's what I'm saying be
a lot stop stop there look at him this
is more [ __ ] you're into but keep going
and there's a promotion yeah keep going
keep going you'll see might just be a
super muscular dude hope I'm not saying
they're not saying he's on anything keep
going mm-hmm
you'll see it it's promotion for his
band he might get this one see that
there's him there and there's him on
stays awesome look at him is he playing
dude du hast du hast my dude he's a
[ __ ] musician hola oh he's a
guitarist look at him on the flat there
Jim
do with a beautiful [ __ ] guitar
[Music]
I see
Chinn eat your heart some fashion
fashion sense I'm a huge fan Robert
Irfan Marty we're on board huge fan meek
yeah oh holy [ __ ] dude they're [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] up right now no they're
gonna they're gonna have a guitar off
the line you know well look they're men
dude I wish you like to jam like we've
got to start taking guitar lessons we
got a [ __ ] start a band what are we
gonna name the band the Brian's the dick
divers the corgis or the dick diver
Corky killer No divers are us to cross
guys who aren't that cut the basic guys
well you're a little bit more than that
but one white medium guy yeah he's the
greatest he's gonna be a channel about
that big one I don't know what his skill
level is and I don't care he's gonna be
me neither but I think we had a
superstar in the making first rolling
down its fall easy straight and I hope
not no she is why don't we have more gay
why doesn't jump to the top of the page
I don't know is it more his band singing
oh I go up here oh I got a question
Deacon out over this dude right now
that's natural no no look at the veins
in his tummy that that can be I'm just
saying the Golden Snitch tends to sniff
around that dude he's been tested so
many times but we have to and that's him
at 70 be very nice about a weight yeah
he's probably walk at two that's a big
Viking I don't know what it is to set us
just probably he's bleeding
he's got small dragon wings it's what he
has his haircuts of ridiculous I love
him awesome is there any more of him
senior every bit of 45 years old but I
love him really it was races faces
rather it's got thick skin fighters had
thick skin on their friends got hard our
teen on this dude he's awesome right
yeah I'm a fan
how do you know our you know the whole
what an end modern physics good things
mean I can see a bit of a nice blonde
Davis in a googoo porn
what's Google what's Google bro he's in
the old seat what about that one right
there that's one we saw right this one
is it I think so
oh let's play it Jill I see hating on
his music skills
yeah chance awesome on this video I love
this Nordic the Nords the Nords love
this hardcore [ __ ] I love this one super
white there's super white
[Music]
shredder shred city shred that's our
band name shred cigarette city and I got
a mic girl they've coming out
welcome to shred city we all stretch we
got all shred shred no [ __ ] night I
was talking to Julia yesterday and here
he answered every question like a rock
and roller I go how you doing he was
like dude are you saying he's doing well
because Harper sounds like an 80s hair
metal band he was Sammy Hagar the whole
time I mean they're like on a Nordic
life sound like Metallica but not as
good but anyway god bless him
macho
now why would he walks out didn't have
the band sing him out right yeah what
are they saying so Swedish for no reason
is very phonetically similar to English
[Music]
that that hipster drummer don't pay
everyone else is pretty hardcore overall
I had it out with in the drummer
hipsters mix it up with the hips oh they
are the milk they're the milk meat and
wheat eaters they're there they're big
people this is like The Ellen Show of
Nordic it's very you do get super
muscular Swedes and you get those
[ __ ] genetic freaks like you do in
West Africa like it's just a hole oh
yeah different lenders have the voice of
a nordic angel that's a nice way of us
see superstar on your hands UFC market
this time piece does that dude I wanna
you and I jamming like you should be
playing dissolve out with his guitar
yeah just with this solo yeah cheers you
guitar will move on after this I can't
get enough of this [ __ ] is eating it you
slant some pretty easy stuff right now
well this yeah well you know and still
shred a turn oh here but that was a oh
here comes the closer
I like when they lean back like that I
know I want to feel that this is my new
favorite band
my new favorite fighters welcome he's
saying Rollie pollie Dixon no roly poly
dick shadow's oh no he's gone Rolie
Polie dick sand I know
Rolie Polie dick shun dill dick dicks in
know there's like sand in your dick no
yes
you're roly poly and if you're always
saying and saying Roy boy quicksand
either way either way we'll have to look
at it well we have to get the lyrics on
online
I gotta learn no reason wow that's a
super hard in the paint on the Gary tape
man it started with Pablo Acosta and now
we got a new boyfriend
Emile meets Paulette coastal look like
he was a Mila Hey your move pollo
let's see a jam out let's see you shred
the guitar make chin jealous up there
can I tell you what Apollo does when
they play he just poses quietly jacks
off in the corner he poses quietly and
jacks off well you could do that or you
could just sit there with a heavy piece
and I think he's got a heavy piece cuz I
was I don't think so I would think that
come up you know what Paul was doing
well he's playing the guitar
Paulo's jacking off in a plane like
Weinstein no I think Paula had had a lot
of work getting his three-piece set into
that Cup and he was like it's American
you know they don't make them the same
way well I see Russians from the worst
because from Mother Russia is that
shredded [ __ ] ripped right that's a big
smash tag Betsy I choose to believe he
doesn't do steroids
um Tony does I've never seen anything
all the sketches all a bottom
yeah that's insane it's a Viking power
sons rest of his [ __ ] that's a crazy
muscularity they're not all the pictures
of ladies on his Instagram though is
there they will just rock your honey you
don't think I was looking for that I was
down well there's one lady he might be a
guy who's like keeping it single Oh
Nordics spurns holding the girl there no
that's enough Felice Herrig let's please
hear that's not a fighter
no that's not her they make a cute
actually that's what I'm saying that's
not his girl a cute couple
let's see what else we got I thought she
was weird
yeah she's bodied up yep he takes a good
you say how's he madam wait a minute oh
please no one please go up one please
right there please right there please
right there please now you and I have
been naked bro but we're not doing
there's something very fishy going on
hehehe here okay cuz that's just a shed
and they're standing on rocks and Sweden
couldn't be happier with that quad
development couldn't be happier I'm
impressed by his glutes though here's
the long ass he's got a long as that
other one's got his beautiful boy have
the Bubble Boy
that's a bubble butt right there that's
an odorous quads are jack yeah yeah he's
got some Jack Jack quads
he's got a high ass though it's high up
it's long it's likes long it's a long
man it goes right up to the middle of
his back were marching through snow was
boys is a it's a peach he looks like a
quarter he looks like a quarter mile are
in the Olympics that's just a high ass
that's made for looks like a Viking
that's gonna equate your town and [ __ ]
your man he can dart through a forest
he'd don't [ __ ] your mouth yeah you can
set your town on fire
don't take your man this is why you
don't nap and you don't stay in the
forests of Norway because if your nap in
the first one somebody sleeps with his
mouth open
he's darting about and he says hey
there's a mouth I look if if he if he
indulges if he ruts on other men cuz
that ass I'm that guy if you if you
close that's a nice ass dude mmm I don't
know what's happening I don't either I
appreciate him me too I'm trying he's
what your top 5 favorite if he comes out
gay I'm gonna like him even more
obviously like he's not gay I don't know
I'm gay if he is though it's all good
yeah but he's not he's a rock star rough
he's a stud he's a stud I love I love a
lot of tired we got a new work where
we're fans we're fans of you I just
thought it's best to introduce you to
him
I very much appreciate all right all
right I'll be going over his Instagram
later we're in the privacy of my uh chin
what'd you do this weekend man besides
rip people's faces off
I forgot actually what I did this
weekend once you start MJ MJ did stuff
right jump on that Mike gangjae oh we
liven it up with photos of you guys
exact same photo like I have yet on our
Instagram when we're shooting firing TV
when we did the naked and afraid episode
where we've had our weird butt naked we
got a couple we got socks in the front
we got pots too I wore that song um
what'd you do MJ I was supposed to go
fishing I'm super bummed of them catch
my first fish but I got called into work
at Lulu really Yeah right there oh my
mouth doesn't afford kedo though so I
don't know well now you got a nice ass
I've always been known for my ass too
we're kind of asked up there and dict up
yeah dict out the front we're lucky that
we're [ __ ] up in a stop you know god
bless
so you show us go fishing with his go
fishing um my friend he works for this
fishing dock in Ventura so he does like
all the deep-sea I don't know anything
about to go deep-sea fishermen we're and
go to Lake casitas I don't know exactly
what is that either mm-hmm but I was
gonna cook a fish if I caught one but
you've never gone fishing okay I've gone
fishing one time and we went to Lake to
see this and I didn't I didn't care just
a la fishing man well yeah I grew up
fishing people skip used to take me
fishing I used to go all the time
so you've never been it's my goal by the
end of the years go fishing trying I'll
bring back some food so don't make you
guys cookies okay [ __ ] cookies no five
and six and I won't get my grimy old
paws you feeling way better way better
like 100% now so I'm still going crazy
they're gonna wrap off a canoe once all
right bro well this is not in here and
it just came to me I'm like in late
winter
talking when and Wolfeboro I had to [ __ ]
we were hunting we were fishing for
[ __ ] trout I was cold and bored and I
stuck my ass those outside of the
[ __ ] thing and I you Chum the water
up thirteen yeah thirteen work that
Lululemon's going good MJ is it all
females that work there no there's
actually like a few guys that work there
actually that's a very interesting move
to work at luly's a smart move honestly
if you're single and younger and you're
trying to meet some girls I agree ahead
and then everything for the Lululemon
like they want you to interact with the
community so we're always doing like
workouts at different gyms boxing gyms
it could be means yeah now I'm gonna say
something your employer employee might
frown upon this mmm-hmm I've never met a
tough guy when Lululemon in the gym
whenever I see Louisville I think soft
that's fair guys have a 40 percent I
Love You Man discount now so if any of
the listeners are interested they're
trying to get males into it right yeah
for me I if I see a guy in the gym and
he has Lululemon I'm like obviously
don't walk into Lou I'm before it gets
so pricey but it's really nice it's so
expensive I just a new company [ __ ]
with you guys business though is a gym
shark was it what gym shark
nope never love I like gym sorry I've
never heard of it great name though
no that's off this off Third Street now
it's super-simple name and they're
killing it what is it it's man I forget
what it is super simple name they're
killing it though and they're little
they're not cheap either
probably lemon is really expensive right
it's super expensive I'm I mean they
take care of you as an employee that's
only I just got my first pair yesterday
of Lululemon pants it's women's gear I'm
gonna have to get you you can have to
get me a pair of black mediums
maybe you just heard me some tights if
your way and Lou Lemon I'm gonna punch
in there oh yes miserable I'm gonna if
you go into Venice barbell club with
right Lulu no but here's though I'm
gonna I'm gonna color in the yellow
rocket you know what maybe we should
change the game maybe Lululemon's listen
it's like you know what we need some
aggro dudes rocking on get me extra
small I want to really
face in there this random clothing what
no no no no there's a brand company they
sent me a bunch of stuff so I can start
wearing it for the gym that's called
lift heavy apparel they sent me a care
package this weekend lift heavy apparel
yes heavy lift heavy apparel super
badass super lean super comfortable
though everything like fit perfectly
pockets like a super big fan of lift
heavy apparel that's cool yeah it's just
an interesting name like it's that's
kind of courtly
lift heavy I mean simple they should
just call it workout I think they work
out of the UK that's why lift heavy it's
a different thing yeah it might be good
that's different but super simple hmm
why don't you lift heavy gym clothes I'm
sorry new brands call gym clothes gym
clothes
I want a circling swole then you start
lifting no yeah I want to get strong
though hold up
I love girls like I don't to be it takes
a long time I put on muscle mmm you know
I mean I don't want to get too muscular
it depends on the person certain genetic
cell phone in my town is pretty buff
everyone in Santa Rita the girls are
looking like pretty pretty bad girls
have to be careful because there's
there's like being fit is sexy that's
what's in right and then being buff body
it's like so hot to me like I don't want
to lose that like feminine appeal like
at all like I think girls are super hot
so it's like I love I appreciate like a
good body so I just want to get to enjoy
strong I want some cakes
i I can use my whole life and I could be
with the most professional people I bet
even if I took steroids I would just
never put on muscle no if you take Sara
Jewett
it's very I would look like but I might
look like a skinny guy who just is the
well that's not what your shot that's
not what you're saying
you'd put 100% put on muscle you did
steroids watch this five pounds I don't
know and I don't care
well we're talk about MJ skates right
now working I'm talking about my case
you're fine do you put on muscle easily
or you're just a big I don't know that I
mean now I'm older you know I don't know
yeah big dude for me it's a it's for me
the challenge would be getting super
shredded like I've never been real
shredded right like super like Demi
different body just Jo lift no no just
you squat nope no all genetic her mom is
the same s freaking she need a lot yeah
I feel like girls have big butts usually
deluxe they've good bodies like theirs
having a strong I metabolism hmm like
she says crazy genetics flat pillow yeah
good genetics Dillinger yeah whatever
yokai honestly how yoga is like I think
what saves girls from like putting on
the weight it's a good detox you flush
everything out you feel good as long as
you hydrate after and you drink so much
water to compensate for the water you
lost that you're not snacking in bed to
me I just can't do yoga more than once a
week why it's only once a week
if you not haven't done yelling for
Erica so boring there's over like 30
different kinds of yoga though yeah I
get it though you're stretching right
I'll lift up there's there's pote
there's a yin yoga where you'll hold a
pose for like up to five minutes even
it's all like mental physical like tests
I think it's a moving meditation yoga
there's eight parts of what yoga is the
actual asana the physical practice on
your mat is only one of the limbs
breathing is a limit itself I get all
that I know I know there's a lot that
goes into it I just I don't know I did a
yoga class when I was in Calgary
shoutout to my friend Jen Ruka rookie
yoga and Calgary awesome teacher and it
was a mellow class but I an hour and a
half is a long [ __ ] time yeah and I
actually if you haven't done a while -
too much is too much
yeah she told you 90 minutes she Beach
it was a minute it was an hour 15 it was
very very mellow wasn't yeah she was
taking me through good she knows what
she's doing so it was really good but
I'm just saying Yoga I'd rather stretch
a little bit and then just lift her box
up on I should I start doing again I had
this ridiculous area teacher at Equinox
and Sam I get ridiculous body well the
best thing really she did hip-hop yoga
that's more fawful yeah there's a lot
hip-hop yoga now - it's like getting me
I do uh I do
I told you that I do a little bit weight
lifting so I'm an Olympic weightlifter
so you guys can talk about stretching I
move I fight iron so a lot of guys going
to lift heavy yo do you stretch before
you workout
okay well I don't see a lot of lifters
don't write and they come in with like
bad knees tight hips for me I'm 50 I
have to but ya jinyo not yoga not for
you huh I tried it once I think that's
all I'm j-just well just destroy me I
try for like a week you know on YouTube
follow maginot 40 surprises lifts well
about the class you need be in the
environment dude I do the hot you'll get
eight and Santa Monica and the virus you
gotta be in the environment you can't do
that home I don't know work as we did on
it
those half-hour workouts best things
I've ever done I love them yeah they're
good like a half hour yeah it was like I
felt like that's all I needed
I felt so good what were you saying
though chin I just I wanted to do it
just to learn it so if I enjoyed it then
I would go to do it it that's not real
though that's like saying no I like
fighting and like girl would you do I
I'd hit the heavy bag in my home yeah
that's not real because you can get
injuries in yoga for sure like the
hip-hop yoga the only thing I have to
say about it is usually teachers teach
it too fast and they're trying to go
with the beat and then a lot of injuries
happen because you're going through
these poses that are hard on your
shoulders and hard on your knees if
you're not landing them properly and
you're not connecting your breath to it
so I think it a lot more injuries can
happen with like people try to be fun
with it like probably so serious no way
inhale the negative I play hip hop in my
classes like my classes are hip hop but
I still teach the forty posture sequence
and mine's an hour-and-a-half class if
you hit everything I mean there's our 15
modifications of and then there's an
hour because it's 40 postures you repeat
twice and it has a core workout and a
squat workout so and then a mini
shavasana which is like you're attending
meditation your corpse lies within it so
that way you can recuperate you did - MJ
let's heat it's hot would you do that in
Valencia area I don't wanna say exactly
I can't you do something down here I
know I'm well that's why I like right
now I please you say weeks out and tell
them out of this place so once I figure
out like where I'm gonna be doing then
I'm gonna try to figure out news I will
come at least once a week if you don't
hear okay yeah
that was fun class I come in full
spandex I come in speedo but techno
until my class I won't do the techno I
like I come in somebody who like
transfer I don't do that in white hair
black and I put tile all over like oh my
god it's days yes and I'm doused in
Cologne
I mean I'm pulling the mat up right here
I'm gonna hang out in the back be in the
back cuz I like ass dude I told you last
time I did hot you haven't done it since
this guy suck obviously a hater but I
showed up not late blast later so I was
all the way in the back and Sheila in
Santa Monica there's dimepiece women all
over we're stretching you're doing this
and you know I'm look I like the look in
the mirror to see my bad stuff like that
he goes Brandon eyes up front eyes up
front foot stay focus it's not gaze at
everyone me I get so mad hey bud piss me
off and then one day you after class I'm
beating you up you that's fine I'm Safi
around
hey I'm gonna whoop your ass alright
cool shove you around not BTB shove you
around
tease start to cry but then when then
one guy went to get what are yours wool
I didn't say water break you get water
my tell you is get water if I can return
that guy's yeah
can i play man you should do and then I
went he's right man see I timed in to
try and win his friendship I went he's
right he told you when to get water if
you need water time bids if you're truly
in your yoga though when people are
getting water you should be able to be
so focused in your meditation that
people getting water moving better like
why I don't like it when teachers like
oh you're not supposed to grab water
when when the teacher doesn't say it if
you're so focused you're on your mat you
have to be you shouldn't there should be
no outside distractions this I'm 34 I'm
my water there I'm gonna drink water
wind oh [ __ ] I want regardless of your
rules
matter of fact finally like holding this
pose I'll probably chill and look at all
the girls for you move on I'm gonna tell
you what and I'm being with a boner I'm
being dead serious is what you should do
that's what you should do
alright because you're very strong why
do we have to say this I would yeah I'm
I don't know it's adorable this is me
right now skew true if you ever have a
problem and you want to beat somebody up
of course you would never do that I
don't want to
second of all you never want to shove
anybody I don't want you know you could
do you're strong enough to grab that
yoga guy when everybody leaves and shake
I'm a very violent I'm in the mouth
shake him supervise there's that good
like that and then he pees a little bit
and poos a little bit he can't go to the
cops and say he shook me he can't so
you're in that way justice all bro I
know but you're gonna be like I what
shook you the judge is gonna be like
shook he shook you there's no proof of
that and he's just done then when when
the judge going yeah he shook you you're
in the back on worldstar to my channel
and see all shook up oh you bout to get
all shook up oh you know did I get a
piece so bad let me help you I'm going
to squeeze your dong dry I'm going to
twist it super dry
well smack around some right now see
he's got we have candy in the studio and
I mean shitty candy like starbursts and
big bags of like Hershey things home
enjoy I'd say that shitty candy no it's
it's really good like I'm I have a
Hershey bar in my mouth right now wait
why do you say this I eat candy every
day every time we do a podcast now and
it's not good for me well twice a week
you're right I think it would be really
should be right what do you guys do some
kind of enter sounds good first one is
Langella ball is arrested in China for
shoplifting mmm I don't know anything
about these dealing so he's from the big
baller family why are they three
brothers no soup all with his two
teammates
oh so this just came out let's see what
this is for you traveling in China huh
just shoplifting yeah okay yeah is he
he's already at University of UCLA
because I know all the brothers have
scholarships it says yeah for near Los
Angeles UCLA is cooperating with the flu
oh well nobody's stolen what the [ __ ]
you doing stealing when in China there's
Lonzo ball you know it's there yeah so
my men's hell living large in Hawaii
where what there's a little thing on
time until a shoplifting like I know
where the shopping store I was like yeah
with Lonzo ball I mean this is just
weird his brother's not playing Grady
either the rumor is he soft and the
league and stuff like that so you know
they have their own reality show the
whole family does Wow
Leigh the Kardashians the ball with on
Facebook mm-hmm
just got picked up for season 2 you're
the first person that introduced it to
at least me and a while ago right I had
no idea they even existed man they blew
up yeah I saw him on YouTube moans I got
this is fascinating the whole family and
they're all really really good at
basketball and the dad's dynamic yeah
dad's a trip it's gonna be a pretty damn
good show actually what are you going on
it's already happened yeah it's all
right I got picked up for season 2
it's give me interesting you know
because the the dad's the one who does
all the [ __ ] talking and then the son
he's playing alright for rookie B's not
like you LeBron James or anything
he's at some good games he got shut out
his first game against this superstar
and then you know it's tough because
there's all this pressure on from his
father
maybe he'd maybe then he's doing rap
videos oh he has like his rap song and
how good he's gonna be in stuff like
that see me tough to compete with you
know the the westbrook's of the world
and Steph Curry's he definitely needs
maybe he needs a year two years to kind
of decompress and get into the flow yeah
it doesn't really work like that no no
good I'm red shirt you kind of like
bring you know God no red shirt you yeah
the MBA now first on traffic you're in
the starting lineup now that's it it's
the NBA you're how old 21 days 21
something to note then behave completely
so plenty old enough playing oh that's
good man yeah and also since you played
in college cuz we really have the rule
where you can't skip college anymore you
have to go through I mean yeah you have
to it seems so young you feel for Mara
Kobe's start playing and then bare
things 18 so you know LeBron 18 so these
guys were able to skip college now
there's a room and try college man
children [ __ ]
so he's 20 you know people compare him
to Jason Kidd but yes there's little
ways to go
how tall is he 66 point guard six six
yeah you can pass I like him though I
root for these guys the Kardashians are
basketball whatever Melo Lonzo what else
you got chin do you want to talk about
that baseball player that just passed
away you know airplane crash we just saw
this one holiday yeah run holiday he was
a beast if you remember early holiday
man what was it like a commercial flight
let's see probably Tuesday in Gulf of
Mexico light sport aircraft damn ten
miles south of st. Petersburg so some
just regular private plane [ __ ] man
Roy did not make a mayday call before he
went down and they were good I mean just
made eight calls really do anything some
you can get caught in you just purchased
it last month sometimes you can get
caught in clouds and my father was a
pilot for a long time just gonna get
caught in clouds and you just literally
end up not even knowing if your right
side up and then you can hit the ground
first time animate I mean a superstar
superstar pitcher if you guys remember
we holiday man that's a bummer
yeah first ballot hall-of-famer for sure
[ __ ] with planes man actors yeah my dad
used to fly one a small one I'd be in
there with way more dangerous right flew
across the country with him it's just
you feel the air you you're dealing you
know you're you're and if you go down
you know we were 4,000 feet when I think
JFK jr. lost control of his aircraft to
4,000 feet and plummeted into the ocean
and we were over the ocean at 4,000 feet
my father goes look down I go Jesus and
he goes this is the height that the
plane started to dive according to is it
went up way up dude
you you don't want to die that way you
don't want to be waiting for you to hit
the water or the ground in a plane as
it's tumbling as its falling year no the
worst no well you know most commercial
flights if they crash it's only taken
off and landed once you're in the air no
planes ever - some lightning very ran
into each other little crash app and
take off inland almost all yes Julia fly
but even then but yeah you don't listen
Ford crashes playing like that [ __ ] it
yeah my dad Santa Monica Airport was
like your God these things are fast
my father same thing crashed fine
because we're gonna land in the river
smells like now Lynn over there because
now I don't want to hit a house we're
gonna land the rivers can be very cold
like a marine about it now he landed
they found an abandoned airstrip or
something and land and [ __ ] the plan
of total plan he walked away no problem
I think his friend broke his foot
playing that really [ __ ] with no you
don't want it like the one thing I would
want is a helicopter like Kobe Bryant
hats how we can live in Orange County
and fly into LA do you really collide in
the helicopter but I take the chance
almost gotcha have you seen this
helicopter now bring up co e
helicopter then you fly in for the games
every day back and forth no traffic on
that yeah I can it'd be awesome yeah
look at this mr. strip his house has a
helicopter pad that's a hell of a
chopper right there
it's called the Black Mamba and as well
it should be as well it should be look
at that look at that he's parked on top
of the [ __ ] he's Kobe I know but no
track not that famous that famous guy in
Britain died from a helicopter after
Scott Burton died he thought he had a
chopper like that in crashed look at
that you don't hear a lot of helicopter
crashes right I don't know feel like
they're safer than planes um well they
don't collide they just drop like a
stone I mean though
they'll spin mean last time when I came
here that helicopter crash planes yes
all suicides men yeah I was gonna say
not as many so their Lobby knows men
like you don't think we could afford
like the helicopter for magnum p.i in
the beginning quite like to that dough
we needed we need just a glass domes
maintenance its fuel and it's a pilot
that's a lot of money well no no you and
I are as a pilot I almost lost my lunch
I almost lost my lunch I was weird surge
channel you'll be honest no cuz I've
heard about lies engine fail I heard
about this yeah I would type in
helicopter crashes 2017 no no I'm
talking about the system that's built
into the engine they wanted when the
engine dies there's some like reverse
rotation that goes on so it's supposed
to glide yeah I've heard of collides but
I don't know I think you fall like us
yeah I've never seen it happen way more
sense to me than airplanes flying well
get a helicopter yeah that makes sense
because I get a plan ago that's [ __ ]
weird mm-hmm so as you when they're like
their cruise ships in the air those
giant ones like they want to take
Australia there's like double-decker I'm
like this thing's you know fly if you
want to notice you know the I guess the
principle behind flight is very simple
take a piece of paper take a piece of
paper hold it at one end and blow on the
top of it what happens give me a piece
of paper he goes like this it goes down
yeah in fact the opposite happens how
weird is that goes down and
so when I blow on a piece of paper this
isn't a good piece of paper here let me
just give you this one but if I blow on
a piece of paper I blow on a piece of
paper this is gonna sound weird but
you'd think if I blow on it let's see
how it goes up what we've got that one
gets the reason I went up there we go
see that yeah yeah yeah why'd it go up
you think if you blew down on them they
would go down well when molecules when
when air molecules go over something
faster pressure is greater underneath it
it's a physics to law physics
fascinating so if there's more pressure
of this more speed of the molecules
sorry I for all you aerospace our
engineers I'm being really rudimentary
but that is essentially you you design a
wing so that that's what happens so that
the air is travel should over it fast
jet yeah and then you have rudders and
all hang crazy when you won't look at
them yeah the heart in particular that
particular you were steer out your
window my house this wing not gonna fall
off in this story I know how did the
wings not now I got those wings are
tested to actually almost sold out yeah
they the Winx in that you fold up
raising what I don't think and I also
heard you know if let's say for whatever
reason someone opens that emergency door
you're not getting sucked out that's the
movie oh is that true yeah it's not real
because my friend's father used to fly
planes for the Navy or Air Force planes
directly into the eye of a storm he had
special kind of planes that could fly a
job into the eye of the storm to not
only test planes but also to take data
on storms so he'd fly into the eye of
the storm and now a regular blank for
regular playing the regular plane gets
ripped apart it'll get ripped apart in
the eye of a storm in the thunderstorm
not so with these planes they're just
made to [ __ ] just I mean
four-wheeling of the sky that's exactly
right that's [ __ ] great way to put it
you're for before lean on the clouds
it's an awful job yeah you gotta be very
ready for it definitely it's like my
buddy who got
got stranded basically got stuck for 27
hours it at sea in the wintertime as
waves were crashing over the boat and he
couldn't get anywhere he had to just
kind of do a holding pattern because if
he if he didn't if he wasn't steering it
the boat will get he would get thrown
into the rocks and everybody would die
yeah and also when you fall in the water
when in the wintertime you've done bye
bye see you later see you later oh so
don't worry oh do me a favor don't wear
a life preserver why died Titanic yeah
much better to die Titanic so it's very
serious
they had to get a guy from Alaska there
was only one guy they could find cuz the
guy they had in California was like or
wherever it was the Atlantic actually
was he wasn't qualified they had to fly
a dueting from Alaska to get the tugboat
the right but he was the only guy could
navigate those kind of waves that kind
of ocean dude when i when i I've only
been a private jet a few times and when
I was with the creators of Game of
Thrones I wasn't wearing my seat belt
and the guy goes big guy who's put your
seat belt on I who gives a [ __ ] man I
never run my sleep on planes yells I'm
these small planes you should he goes
last time we're going he said they were
going somewhere in Ireland on a private
jet and they hit a bump me was almost
Brooklyn that's right
here's I went up and it the last thing I
put here he goes if we I would have told
you I would have broke my neck yes she
was people it happens all the time all
the time dogs my dog I had my dog on the
plane me and my dad suzune and like that
my dog [ __ ] hit the the top of that
plane well he was bad I had to hold my
dog [ __ ] up my pit bull right in the
back dude my father always said to keep
you see both planes are crazy yeah you
hit wind shears you hit wind pockets you
hit like a it's just I'm like whoa
today's a good bad I feel good with
planes either we have come traveling a
bunch on Thursday the air I just feel
like [ __ ] ya know here the people you're
sniffing everyone's farts oh yeah
morning yes there's nothing City Florida
how's the food not better at this point
you've only five first-class the food
I'm like myself a plastic rabbit or I'll
kill you to have good food
back in the day they used to cook foods
right there they do rack of lamb first
class back in the day on Pan Am and
masculine dude they would cook you the
stewardesses would come out and they
would cook broad in ovens when you fly
international some sometimes they'll
strike up those homemade cookies they
come around with hot fresh-baked cookies
to everybody and a wine light I will fly
whatever you want and I'm [ __ ]
they're delicious yeah I had to in it's
rare I do this but when I'm on tour I'm
two [ __ ] on my diet
they gave me one I went this might be
the best cook ever had came back and
went excuse me do you Pam do you have
any more cookies she's like yes we do
I'm I had to hit her up I was
embarrassed about it can I get a few
more cool my mom embarrass the [ __ ] out
of me because my mom and I are sitting
coach right behind first class and they
handed out soft juicy chocolate chip
cookies it's Melanie coach does this my
mother said excuse me are there cookies
back here for us and the woman said no
that's just for first-class use that's
bad manners
I can smell them and it's tempting
they're making my mouth water and that's
bad manners off like this that's bad man
I know Stewart's killed [ __ ] yeah well
I'm sorry to pay for first-class right
like please don't say that that's super
like weird to do that it's funny though
that's bad manner sounds like if they
don't find a voice though Hey
they was wafting into all our nostrils
is there anything better than either
either like this waffle cones like yet
salt & straw and they get Michael does
waffle clothes Cinnabon or fresh-baked
coach said I'm stupid good I can't
realize something have it I judge people
when they eat them I'm like ah you're
gonna die but anyway the middle of
Cinnabon I don't want the card crusty
outside just get can I just buy three
middles Oh stupid just give me three
minutes yeah you getting hot they're
good you get diabetes immediate or they
should from nobody's new laws you don't
see him everywhere now they stare that
my mouth is watering on a Cinnabon well
you know his makes great Cinnabons but
better is Travis over I just I mean they
got some crazy Cinnabon stood I lost all
energy in my body listen I love Travis
over it juice
yeah they don't make a better [ __ ]
like a Cinnabon then Cinnabon easy man
when's the last day at Cinnabon I have
never had a Cinnabon because oh yeah you
judgmental crap I'm an aristocrat and I
don't dine with the peasantry okay I do
walk by Cinnabon and I go enjoy dying in
your diabetes enjoy life because you're
living to the fullest I walk by and I go
I'm skinny and I keep walking
I say things like that awesome what's
nice just like you I'm a cheater your
hippos Travis walk Travis makes great
stuff but he doesn't make it better
chicken sandwich then chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a he's got some sandwiches
there they're chicken soup chicken
sandwich they have something to say
those chicken sandwiches have something
their waffle fries their wall flies are
great do such the one knock on juiced-up
their fries yeah I know you listen this
tribes your fries are awful me and Brian
don't want see it in person because we
don't have backbones your fries at juice
door cause I don't have back hair of
Bowl I've actually only had them once
been they weren't we've had them twice
yeah and when you are my god you think
we should try them getting lit yeah
let's do it it's like a no wait
[ __ ] hey Brody don't you cut them in and
baking them I want you baking my fries
you fry them if there's just something
they're missing something yeah I don't
know what it is you know what they're
tasteless the worst I've ever had yeah
I'm sorry Travis and I mean ever since
q-value thousand otherwise they are but
could you give us some sort of dessert
on the house yeah we're there all the
time
sometimes he does yeah they do don't go
sometimes not often enough I want
special treatment me too I think we are
asking for since we pay their light bill
for a little a little like a special
treat when our beak wet my [ __ ] beak
bro the way you want our beak couple
piece pizza slices on the house hey
sunshine I know your great chef I'm a
friend to my left I'm a friend of my
left the guy who works out a lot he's
shaking you shaking you want to get
shook up homo shook I'm only gonna show
Murr you're doing that in your home Oh
shook up oh hey beat we're only gonna
shake him if he gives us those shitty
fries again you give me those [ __ ] nice
name don't
time you ever had a bad fry it's hard to
[ __ ] up fries I know he said genius at
everything except for fries I've never
had a bad fry my life except for that
price he'll make you the best bond me
rotas you name it the best chili [ __ ]
filmography it's a restaurant or chicken
[ __ ] you chicken tastes all the same
their chicken is the best chicken you've
ever had it's so juicy so juicy you get
the fries you're gonna throw it back to
their face you're all shook up oh no way
members shake people what else you got
so I want you to shake him like a shake
shack oh I had a Shake Shack burger I
have to say that the one with her some
ice cherries oh my gosh mode Airport
pepper pepper smoked pepper pepper
cherries and and it was there it was
there with bacon I don't what it was it
was so much that's healthy and Cinnabon
it was so [ __ ] delicious we had Shake
Shack in London right so when they shop
once shut the [ __ ] up about it
yeah tato blonde went there's a potato
bar they nice delicious oh you know
shake Shack's are in New York and the
line was out the Gazoo in them so they
went sizzler and they opened all over
the place they they're they're simply
delicious
Oh fantastic simple too simple but super
tasty go to the next current event I
like [ __ ] you've been cast in for almost
two hours
lovely yeah we've been PC in for almost
two hours casting up cats no couples
faster couple casters get cast on it
give me the next one we can't okay away
today so Will Smith and Jada Pinkett
Smith gave Tyrese five million dollars
because you know he's going through
these legal woes and financial troubles
twist a script to stop being on the
Internet
and the first thing you do much money oh
oh god dude five million wheels you have
to make me sir
Will Smith Will Smith they gave him ten
five million dollars I don't believe it
yeah I believe it so Tyrese himself
posted a super clear they are kind of
close when we show up for each other
there's nothing can be done I repeat
nothing my wife kept the news away from
me because I've been on with lawyers all
day but our family and our sister Jada
pinkett-smith and my brother Will Smith
just sent us five million dollars to
help keep us afloat you guys asked me to
get off and staff dinner now
my daughter's legal fees will be paid I
will listen the Smiths and their whole
family has always shown up for the
Gibson's uncle will you're an uncle for
a real and I'm saying again if you guys
are out there in Atlanta area please
vote for Keyshia bottom someone my
daughter looks up to a lot I play Miss
America there's no worries I'm super
best I wouldn't tell anyone either
how about Will Smith Will Smith was like
God doc shut the [ __ ] up here's five mil
to stay off Instagram yeah so that
happened and then he starts posting more
on Instagram their random stuff but
check this one out this is probably the
craziest one he's just losing it it's
just a teddy bear you can hear him in
the background
cried hey listen to me before you go to
sleep whatever you do get to my facebook
facebook.com 4 / Tyrese facebook-dot-com
forward-slash Tyrese before anything
else by the way that's all is why'd you
do it like it's a secret did you go go
to Facebook / for Tyrese Facebook okay
so he just says go to Facebook Theriot
mess and then of course know it's a
Facebook and there's just random
postings of yeah he's everything weird
business he's I guess I'm broke I'm
gonna take my shot it's almost 7 a.m.
and I'm headed to court Taylor's is a
silent protest he's a real narcissist
what silent protest we're watching a
meltdown
yeah for all the men and all of the
ghettos around the world who didn't have
the money to have better representation
for the case and accusations didn't
wasn't making a lot of money hell yeah
you see the guy from Dwight May or
whatever a white white
call them out so fun whoo-hoo what white
mare I have it on my phone sleep famous
yeah white famous Jay Pharoah I say yeah
so funny yeah I think sorry I mean I was
laughing wait iris I'll find it for you
let's just check this out since you're
finding it this is a tyreese's most
recent post just one mom thank you to
coca-cola for the product placement
we'll sell that jacket to pay your bill
you know my Will Smith wired ain't a man
yet he's awkward as [ __ ] so go to my
facebook calm voice last Tyrese about to
jump on there I want a jet go fly to
Atlanta to go support my girl keep a
report autumn today is the last day she
can vote you can't vote for if you don't
live in the city
Atlanta oh so you're gonna fly out in
that chinchilla all leather jacket in a
private jet and you need five million
from Will Smith I'll make more I need to
complain as a victim to everyone online
need money for legal bills I mean that's
that's that's what you do right now
something's wrong with him some see
really seriously is wrong with them yeah
but uh yes he got five mil from from
them to get off the internet and that's
and there's constantly going on the
internet stay about it did you not find
it I know it's so funny I'm sorry it's
so so white there you could probably
look it up cuz he basically they fail
from white famous yeah and he duty on
Instagram I think and he was talking to
he was talking to Tyrese and making fun
because I guess they had their thing
going on
we are Yuri fritz about is the black guy
going making with the fat black guy no
it's not fat oh because act like that
guy that's great oh that one right there
there there it is right there watch this
yeah what's this crap guys can't wait to
finish film in the movie right oh yeah I
can't believe you're actually going
first of all Tyrese shut your mouth you
need to fall back like Whitney Williams
Tyrese you understand you only have two
lives and every fast and furious
star maybe if you weren't so busy
bitching at me and bitching that tank
and bitching at Ginuwine you can make
some money Tyrese Tyrese look at me he
says rocky you're an amazing B level
actor buddy I mean maybe you should stop
trying to be a Tyler Perry live-action
film and go down to the Hair Club and
get your life back perhaps being bald is
it working out for you it's working out
great for me LeBron's baby last thing
Tyrese if they're really out here
struggling maybe it's worth giving
coca-cola call and see if they'll take
your candy ass back do-do-do-do-do
Tyrese is a jackass 2019 Dwayne what was
that I don't know all the inside scoop
of that but I like that guy he cracks me
the [ __ ] he's super talented I guess man
it seems like it I don't know what this
show is he a comic yeah
oh he's special on Showtime he's gonna
say that live now he's the guy who left
Senate live with our bouquet Q he's
better than that video he does great
stuff man
yeah well anyway war terrorism I just
feel like Tyrese is a guy who has its
you know it's like so embarrassed but I
think something's wrong with him so so
like this church shooter in Texas or
this guy in Vegas I think these people
are crazy I use their creator Tyrese to
the know I think there's I think that
there's no like when we kind of clown
I'm where we figure out what's wrong
with them
there's something wrong with them like
there's something wrong with this whole
thing Tyrese is on that level
I think his career is not going well I
don't even and I think he's having money
issues and he's famous and he can't book
gigs and he's having a Mel no no no I
think he has I think he's bipolar or
something's wrong with him like
clinically it's what I'm saying my
god-dd I think I think what he has
looking at a very little different well
obviously but I'm not saying he's a mass
murderer or what I'm saying is that with
we all pile on these guys and it's kind
of fun to do but actually I think that
some of my Tyrese like I was listening
to them going there searching his
computer this texture shooter there
certain computer
motive there's no motive he's [ __ ]
crazy he's a madman okay done and I
think someone like even like on a lower
level Tyreese who's having this meltdown
something's he needs help he needs a
[ __ ] professional help I don't know
what's up maybe there's something wrong
with his brain I don't [ __ ] hey
there's not maybe things aren't going
SuperDuper it's not that's not how
normal people behave even when they're
depressed there's something wrong he's
taking this out to all of us because I
used to like love to hate on him and now
I just feel bad for him I guess that's
what I'm saying
interesting what else you got you let's
see all right this is in Miami so a
drunken girl was causing yeah let me see
it here you go so she's been carry out
carried out by cops I'm actually even
giving them a hard time to begin with no
[ __ ]
she slaps the back was head minutes
beside his face then she slaps her I
can't do that as a cop you gotta show a
little more restraint yeah you can't be
a giant but I don't know if you I don't
know he took a lot of heat I don't know
if he was already getting hit that was
the last straw I don't know and hey and
I'm gonna tell you this right now I feel
like it was such a reaction
she probably hit him in the eyes I got
it [ __ ] and then he's like oh no I don't
know you're allowed to do that I think
aren't you aren't you allowed to do that
if you're fending for your safety or
something like like is she trying out
your eyes if a small girl slap shot in
the back your bald head says of me when
that small but she's small you're
allowed to hunt anything I hate him
Padre slapped her back but yeah well
they haven't released the guy's name yet
no I'm a cop you get away with that cops
if you're trying to get somebody out and
they're swinging at you and they may
have caused a problem and all of a
sudden she hits you like she bangs you
to hit you again you know I don't know
there are better ways to do it of course
obviously I'm not saying you should
smack somebody unconscious but I don't
know what happened before that yeah I
don't know what's gonna heal get away
with that
Ross Licata respond with the right hook
to free his face yeah it can't be
sunshine girls man it looked like an
open end but either way it was hard yeah
I wonder what that is though I think you
get her I think you're
to defend yourself in that position I
think you're allowed to say I'm trying
to get her out I'm trying to get her out
she's resisting arrest essentially even
though she's drunk right so she hit me
she hit him in the top Butthead and she
came back hit him in the face as he's
trying to is what navigating stairs and
then he kind of hit her back I don't
know how I don't know what that I don't
know how you what happens there it's
interesting I understand the human
reaction I do that's I actually
understand as a person has done to a man
woman I understand you you I don't know
what happened before that you're in a
heightened state somebody hit you I'll
say this though I want my cops have more
restraint than that I understand that
that's fair I think that's fair can't be
hidden girls in the face yeah it's not
like she saw a [ __ ] gotta go there's
none of that human reaction but when
you're a cop and we talked about
stressful situations it's your job yeah
it's your job and also there's six other
cops restraining the girl she's being
carried out yeah but technically he gets
away with that technically I'm sure yeah
technically in a situation yes sure
because you're you're gonna do those
things like what do you want me to do
what you know well so they they had a
guy guy had a knife and he got shot
and they said why don't you tell the guy
to drop the knife and the guy goes
because a knife can be more dangerous
sometimes than a gun when you say die it
was really cool that homeless guy or
some guy had a knife big knife and in
the cop shop the cop shot you said I'm
sorry the cop shot him and then I saw
they showed this picture of so while
back they showed a picture of a guy a
cop who got cut up through his leather
jacket by a crazy dude with a knife and
man when you see what a knife can do oh
my [ __ ] god the guy survived but his
back looked like but I mean you know and
so and it might put you out of work
forever so ya know kind of crazy another
lady getting pulled out by a cop so this
Alabama fan was smoking in the stadium
and it's illegal to do it there the cop
asked me to put it out and I'll show you
what happened there's an older lady -
he's telling her to put it away
so she puts the smoke in his face
[Music]
and now she's acting like a victim
[Music]
yeah see I don't have a problem with
this I don't either I don't think that's
excessive she's completely acting you
want you wanna be a badass and want your
cigarette and try and burn the cop you
ain't get arrested I agree she's drunk
probably she's an [ __ ] she seems like
an [ __ ]
yeah she's being removed yeah yeah that
gets to a point where you're like you're
behaving this way now what do you
literally remove you or shake you or
bring Brendon shopping and give you
anything there's no shakin most hmm I
get what's gonna shake accord you don't
Brandon don't shake look gorg let's take
a look see how we bring it back with you
fans you see how we bring it the [ __ ]
back it's called all the circle Oh easy
all right so someone someone's gonna
quit Twitter on a certain day and that
person deleted Donald Trump's actual
twitter twitter account see ya click
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're cool see ya I'm
out
god I'm looking at Kylie Jenner out
there she I looked at Donald Trump than
I look at Kylie Jenner whoever her
doctors are they should win a Nobel
Prize because she is painfully gorgeous
mm-hmm yeah good old Dom type move by
the Twitter guy
what did patton oswalt say he said he
looks like he's covered in cheeto dust
on his special yeah um there is he looks
so outraged he just looks like yeah
those eyebrows is nhm that's pretty much
it all right a little awesome you drop
some knowledge on the flight yeah I got
a good oh yeah I did I got a good
dropping knowledge oh that was
interesting too you know do you [ __ ]
do you know do you know that working
mothers women who work outside the home
are more likely to have jobs women whose
mothers worked outside the home are more
likely to have jobs themselves are more
likely to hold supervisory
responsibilities these jobs and
higher wages that women whose mothers
stayed home full-time according to a new
study the men raised by working mothers
are more likely to contribute to
household chores and spend more time
caring for family members that's kind of
crazy and that's finding and that and
that is true across 24 countries damn
yep
and I was like damn man so if you work
as a woman and you feel like you're not
there for your kids take heart you might
be doing the best thing you can do
you're setting a great example for your
children the power to working mothers
but raise your kids yeah for sure but
get back in the kitchen my mom was there
by the way raising kids a full-time job
god damn i watch my horse I watched my
wife go through all the go through all
I'd rather go through buds it is a
full-time [ __ ] job school and all
that [ __ ] anyway shout out shout out to
women guys huh shut all them are women
hey guys I'm gonna tell you this right
now I know where I'm gonna be I know
where you're gonna be
ah this Thursday's right where you're
gonna be this Thursday I'm in Charlotte
comedies on you [ __ ] Thursday o'clock
Charlotte Friday Nashville Saturday
Nashville yeah Sunday Columbus which is
sold out all of them are almost sold out
get tickets right now to fat K dot-com
Charlotte you're up Thursday then
Nashville I'm there Friday night and
Saturday night at Zanies they just
released more tickets at those three the
other ones are sold out t fat K calm
I'll shake you November I'll shake ya
shake you know but I'll shave 17th and
18 November 17 anything I'm in New York
City Gotham comedy club then I'm in Utah
at wise guys Thanksgiving weekend wise
guys Utah Thanksgiving weekend you know
free turkey cops coming club December 7
8 & 9
San Francisco T back a calm get him this
is the finally kid we're out